the cinnamon sticks black peppercorn
green cardamom that's muy Subedar head
chef and co-owner of militant dairy
kitchen in the heart of San Francisco's
Civic Center district and he's making
every South Asian restaurant staple
chicken tikka masala real aficionados
however don't even call it chicken tikka
masala
to them it's ctm and that's true all the
way from the British Isles to the
California coast our number one selling
item by far hands down is chicken tikka
masala hey guys I'm sana and today we're
exploring the origins of chicken tikka
masala its popularity and why the future
of curry houses across the United
Kingdom in particular is under threat
okay so the first thing you need to know
about CTM is that there's a lot of
people who say it's not from South Asia
it's actually British whoa okay kind of
chickens think on masalas origins are
often traced back to Glasgow Scotland
where a number of restaurants claim to
have been the first to cook the dish
starting in the 50s 60s and 70s these
stories often center around one
particular Bengali immigrant and a
restaurateur by the name of aliena the
Aslam who ran the sheesh mahal
restaurant that still stands today
reports from the time say that a
customer at sheesh mahal sent back their
chicken dish claiming it was too dry or
bland and when it was returned to the
chef he added a marinade consisting of a
can of tomato soup yogurt and a mixture
of spices or masala except that might
actually not be that accurate either
according to Sean Carey a researcher who
studied curry houses in the UK sea
team's origins are actually a lot more
complicated some people claim it was its
origins lie at the moti Mahal restaurant
in Delhi
others say Glasgow and others say a
Bangladeshi chef invented it somewhere
in the UK I think like all these
questions it's very difficult to know
the historical truth but what I would
say is that is entirely possible that it
was simultaneously invented in different
parts of the world whatever the true
story behind chicken tikka masala is it
took off becoming a signature dish for
South Asian restaurants across the UK
and the US the Korean does see we have
over 12,000 curry houses and the curry
house itself contributes 4.2 billions to
the British economy every year so it's a
very popular so when chicken tikka
masala become number one it means that
the national dish is not fish and chips
anymore
in the early 80s CTM was so popular in
the UK that it was being sold
prepackaged at the popular Waitrose
supermarkets by 2001 the UK's foreign
secretary Robin cook hailed chicken
tikka masala as a truly British dish and
invention with a chicken thick up being
Indian and the masala being British
because the British desired a gravy to
be served with their meats chicken tikka
masala is now a true British national
dish it is a perfect illustration of the
Britain absorbs and adapts external
influences and by 2009 Brits were
consuming 2.5 billion pounds of CTM per
year with approximately 65,000 people
employed all around the UK and
restaurants also known as curry houses
the new migrants that come in very often
are looking to eat the kinds of foods
that they recognize from home so if you
look at supermarkets and that kind of
thing those reflect very often and those
kind of new tastes and the food market
is a relatively easy one for new groups
to enter into but none of this would
have been possible without the migration
of South Asians to the UK to begin with
and that's a story in and of itself and
it starts with you guessed it
colonialism the British landed on the
Indian subcontinent beginning in the
late 1600s as merchants establishing
trading posts across a number of cities
under what became known as the East
India Company by the mid 1700s much of
India had come under the control of the
company and a century later India had
become a British colony one notable
immigrant to the UK from South Asia was
Sakia bean Mohammed who after becoming a
captain with the East India Company
moved to London there he established the
first Indian restaurant in the UK known
as the Hindustani coffee house sailors
so-called lass cars from Bengal who were
living in boarding houses and of course
those boarding houses the men would have
been supplied with food and out of that
supply of food started small waterfront
cafes and that's really the origins of
the present-day Indian curry trade
fast-forward to the 1950s and 60s when
immigration laws were eased during that
time the UK saw significant increase in
the number of South Asian immigrants and
this changes a lot mass migration really
happens after 1947 we start to get
smallish numbers through the fifties of
migrants coming for work because the UK
was looking for a kind of labour to a
star for shortages and then particularly
for South Asians through the 50s and
1960s and then in larger numbers through
the 1970s and 1980s when you get family
reunification particularly from Pakistan
and Bangladesh so that's when you start
to get the formation of larger settled
communities across the UK always linked
to kind of areas of work
today the South Asian community in the
UK is approximately 5% of the population
with visible communities in all major
cities including London Bradford Glasgow
Birmingham and Manchester which is home
to the famous Currie mile there's also
the famous Brick Lane in London's East
End it's the home of the country's
Bangladeshi community known as Bangla
town and it's known for its many curry
houses this area of Bangla towns was
predominantly settled by Bangladeshi
families it's always been a an incoming
area you've had Jewish people Irish
people all sorts of people come in here
but while the South Asian communities
grown considerably over the decades it
does face a number of political economic
and social challenges all of which are
showcased around curry houses in the UK
recently immigration laws have deeply
impacted the ability of South Asian
restaurants to bring over chefs and
waiters from South Asia this has
resulted in a massive shortage of South
Asian workers and thus the shutting down
of numerous restaurants over the years
and with the lack of South Asian chefs
restaurants have had to hire Eastern
European immigrants who now work in
curry houses in the thousands but brexit
threatens even the employment of those
workers dregs it is going to happen very
shortly not not far to go and we still
don't know what going to be happen it's
Deal or No Deal
and the thing is if you don't have free
movement then those European will be
also stopped and they'll have to have a
visa to come to United Kingdom praxis is
going to be a problem for the catering
industry nationwide but particularly in
a place like London where huge numbers
of workers come from overseas the curry
houses are particularly affected because
if the children of the restauranteurs
are not coming into the industry you're
going to have to pull in people from
overseas former Secretary of State for
international development breathe' Patel
even tried to gain support for brexit
among curry house owners by saying that
the UK's withdrawal from the EU would
save the industry by keeping Eastern
Europeans out and thus prioritizing
South Asians for restaurant jobs the
future of curry in this country is at
risk because our membership of the
European Union renders us powerless to
control our borders the brexit campaign
was sold to a number of South Asian
communities by people that wanted us to
Europe on the basis that you know if we
weren't tied to Europe we could expand
back into our broader networks of people
so that the routes to South Asia to and
from South Asia would open up it was a
very strongly kind of nostalgic Imperial
idea that Britain could reconnect with
its Empire we are actually struggling
for the skilled chef even low-skilled
people that needed within the car
industry so hence there is like three to
four carriers that are closing every
week and that's not a good news for the
British economy neither for the Asian
community in the United Kingdom there's
also the changing face of neighborhoods
as South Asian communities like the
Bangladeshi community struggles to keep
their businesses and restaurants open
especially in East London because of
gentrification they're simply being
priced out of the market and I think
also they're being replaced by new
incoming forms of food so somewhere like
brick lane or the curry mile in
Manchester which is very close to here
you'll see those traditional Indian
restaurants being replaced by kind of
shisha places or Lebanese places and
those respect the churn of those areas
because often Indian restaurants are
located in areas of high migration and
and I kind of transitioned and then
there's the straight of racism that
South Asian communities have faced for
decades in the 60s and 70s violent
attacks on members of the South Asian
community by white skinheads became
commonplace and they were fueled by
anti-immigrant rhetoric of the time fast
forward to the early 2000s and South
Asian communities are once again the
target of racism and more specifically
Islamophobia following 9/11 and the 7/7
attacks on the London Underground
everyday violence and hostility is
extreme and that's ratcheted up a lot
since breakfast
so incidents of Islamophobia in
particular a massively high but I think
that's true across all South Asian
communities as well and in the aftermath
of brexit another moment of
anti-immigrant sentiment racially
motivated hate crimes in the UK spiked
to their highest levels ever and
Islamophobic attacks in the UK have also
increased by 26% in 2017 with over 1200
incidents reported so how do we make
sense of this dissonance or disconnect
in British society between its ongoing
love affair for South Asian cuisine
but also its long and complicated
relationship with South Asian immigrant
communities it's always been a kind of
very global society its cultural
identity has always been global but it's
never been happy with representing
itself to itself in that way hey guys
hope you enjoyed the video it was pretty
yummy to make I must say let us know in
the comments what you guys think what
are some of the origin stories that
you've heard about chicken tikka masala
and what your favorite South Asian dish
is and don't forget to like share and
subscribe and we'll see you next week